people have actually looked at the the
whole issue of use-it-or-lose-it
in a way meaning that if you don't have
a partner and you're not having sex
there's research to suggest that you
that it becomes harder and harder as
this is in women I don't know about I
don't know if it's ever hard for men to
orgasm but for women there that there's
some data to suggest that the more
frequently you have arousal and orgasm
the easier it is to achieve and that if
you don't for years and years first of
all you get some atrophy going on
particularly in your later years so
there there is masturbation is actually
a it's kind of a word out the word I
want for it but anyway masturbation is
is a useful strategy for somebody who
seems to be having trouble getting
aroused and having orgasm so you know
yeah you who's gonna get who's gonna
fund that study you know I asked
somebody because I asked there's these
people who are there's a product called
the eros clitoral therapy device and
it's essentially a suction vibrator that
costs four hundred dollars and I said
well why don't we just use your finger
why I mean why you mean if the idea is
that to bring more blood to the genitals
why do you need this $400 device what
masturbation will bring blood to the
genitals that's what happens when you're
aroused and I said well you know
everybody ever done a study like looking
at the how beneficial it is for women
with sexual arousal disorder to
regularly masturbate and this woman said
you know are you nuts look what happened
to joseline elder we can't we couldn't
possibly try to get funded then she had
this great line she said masturbation is
a very touchy subject
you
[Music]